there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock alright we are back once
again doing another true crime show on
episode 136 it is a true crime episode
it is with a bad cord Yeti cord we said
this on the last movie review but if the
audio is not as good as usual it's
because we're having issues with either
the microphone or the cord we're not
really we haven't really figured it out
yet I'm gonna buy a new cord first and
doesn't solve it then we got to buy a
new Yeti yeah they used their 100 bucks
yeah so eventually we'll get around I
mean you know it's I'm sure it's
passable cuz I can usually you know
equalize it and run around with in an
audacity she's not recognizing it yeah
so I don't know we'll figure it out but
hopefully it's not too bad I mean I
think when we did the mobi review I
think it came out alright yeah so but
like I said before I do any more
audiobooks I'm gonna have to either
figure out what's wrong with it or get a
new one they're not that much was buy
another one yeah which you know kind of
sucks but what you gonna do alright so
this show I wanted to do and these were
both specific requests and they were
actually both cases that I wanted to
talk about anyway so I was glad somebody
requested them and I said I'm kind of
gonna put them both together because
well just because I'm trying to double
up on some of our topics just because we
have so many and I want to be able to
like get to some of them so I'm trying
to like put together topics that are
like a similar theme or you know even
even if it's like not even that similar
but it's just like one thing that
connects them that I can kind of put
together so this one I kind of wanted to
do like a sort of Murder on the road
type of thing so we're gonna be talking
about the Colonial Parkway murders or
the Colonial Parkway serial killer or
killers they're not sure if it's one or
more than one and we're also going to be
talking about the highway of Tears which
has been requested many many many many
times and I actually kind of I wrote
about it in
Volume two of the faceless villain and
it's gonna be continuing into volume
three because you know it started in the
60s and is ongoing so they're finding
dead bodies along these roads and yeah
and that may be one guy maybe more than
one they don't know yeah Colonial
Parkway is either one person or possibly
two highway of tears has got to be
several people because it it's gone on
for so long like the first one they know
of was 1969 and there might have been
you know more right you know and so and
they actually some of the cases were
solved and they caught like various
serial killers but then when they did
DNA on that serial killer and tried to
match it with some of the other ones it
didn't match so the highway of tears
seems like a situation where it's just
like a long stretch of road that several
killers seem to be using as a hunting
ground okay for whatever reason all
right
as I said since we've started kind of
recording more shows ahead of time like
farther ahead of time than we used to so
I you know I kind of regret that we
don't get to update like paint new
patrons and stuff like that as quickly
as possible
but of this when we actually have three
new patrons that we wanted to give a
shout out to their names are Trayvon
Antonio and Katrina so hi you guys and
thank you very much for your support
also if you were a $20 and up patron you
either have already got the mugs that I
sent out or it's on its way to you
because I've ordered all of them and
they should be on the way there and we
also did a drawing of our under $20
people and that the men are a winner of
that one was Matt and he got back to me
with his address so I just sent out his
mug as well so you know that it in next
quarter we'll figure out something else
to send if you got any like
recommendations like what you might want
and stuff just let me know and I'll see
if we can accommodate you I think that
you have some movies yeah don't you are
you gonna start give it you know to
certain people I was gonna start giving
out some of my old movies yeah and
they're factory movies in in the Box
we've all will sign them or something
you know yeah if you want like make a
list and I can put like for the next
quarter maybe I can put a list on
patreon and then like people can pick
which ones they want a lot of them are
kind of rare classic movies you know
yeah Universal Soldier he's got all the
shitty movies yeah action movies and
stuff we'll see yeah totally so you
might want that um yeah and speaking of
movies if you didn't see our last movie
review it was the 1971 vampire movie
let's scare Jessica to death so go check
that one out a little bit of an
underrated gem if you haven't seen it so
go check that out so without further
delay let's get into let's do Colonial
Parkway first I didn't know a huge
amount about this case but it was you
know it was recommended a bunch of times
so I started looking into it and it's
really interesting because it's another
one of those Lovers Lane
style murders where is it where's
colonial Park with um colonial it's
actually in Virginia okay and this
actually happened over about a four year
period from in the 1980s and it was much
like zodiac or Son of Sam or something
like that it was somebody targeting
couples in cars not shooting them
usually usually they were stabbed or
strangled or both and it's just like a
really really weird case I was like
listen to this one podcast that I can't
remember the name of it but um they had
done like a whole two-part series on it
and it was like it was really
interesting and I kind of got really
into it but as I said the you know the
FBI is kind of on this case but they're
still not sure if this is one guy a team
of two guys or two separate guys hmm or
maybe more than two because the there
the first the first case in the series
is very similar to like a fifth one that
they're not even sure is related but
then the ones in the middle are kind of
similar but not like the the mo is sort
of similar but not but just different
enough that they're not entirely sure if
this is the same person or if it's like
a team of maybe two hmm which is which
is rare but it does happen alright run
us through it where does this begin all
right so the first um the first murder
in the series this took place in October
of 1986 now there was these two women
Kathleen Thomas she was a stockbroker
she'd been in the Navy like she was a
graduate of the Naval Academy and stuff
like that I think she was about 27 and
she was with her girlfriend Rebecca and
dowse key who was a student at William
and Mary now these two this was 1986
it's kind of rural Virginia so they were
kind of kept their relationship a little
bit on the down-low Kath Kathleen's
family knew about it and we're fine with
it
um Rebecca's family did not know about
it and a lot of their friends didn't
know about they kind of kept it a secret
because you know still kind of a thing
like you couldn't really be open about
it so what they would do
times if they wanted you know privacy or
they want to go on a date or whatever
this they would go out to this Lovers
Lane that's off Colonial Parkway and
then you know they would just go park
like you know so they were doing this on
October 12th 1986 and someone came along
and killed them now these two women when
they were found they had they had been
strangled their throats had been slit
and then whoever had done it had poured
diesel fuel all over the car and tried
to set it on fire which didn't work
because diesel fuel isn't as you know
it's not like gasoline where it'll just
match you got it right but you really
have to yeah it has like a really high
like ignition point so apparently the
person freaked out of that and they
tried to push the car into the York
River but it got hung up like on an
embankment so that's where the car was
found it was like found on the
embankment because apparently I guess
the person either didn't see that it
didn't go into the water or they just
said [ __ ] it I'm out of here
yes probably gone they couldn't push it
anymore right so these two poor girls
here's the weird thing now there was no
sign of that they had struggled the only
sign of a struggle was in I think it was
in Kathleen's hand she had like a clump
of hair like clutched in her hand which
they presumed was from the killer also
the their wallets were still there
neither of them had been raped so this
was not a sexual assault this was not a
robbery
nothing like that now at first because
of the brutality of the crime you know
this is classic overkill not only were
they strangled you know their throats
were slashed so deeply that they were
almost decapitated and that had been
postmortem yeah right so um you know
then the person tried to set the car on
fire and then they try to push it in the
sink so this seemed like a personal
attack a personal vendetta so in that
spirit the FBI the investigators
they start looking into you know
ex-boyfriends ex-girlfriends you know
people who might have known them they
also possible maybe this was a hate
crime like somebody that was targeting
them because there were lesbians you
know so all of this kind of stuff
obviously they didn't know that this was
like a serial killer yet because this is
was the first one in the series that
they know of so you know it already
sounds fishy neither one was bound no
how do you strangle one and keep control
of the other they actually sounds like
two guys well that that is one of the
theories and they also have a couple of
theories about how this person is you
know approaching them and getting them
to comply at first must have a gun and
he Kenny gets him to comply somehow it
isn't kill him but the guy just uses
that to keep control yeah the thing is
though I guess you'd have to separate
them yeah kill them so the other one
doesn't know that the other one is
strangled yeah maybe he says if you move
out if you get out of the car I'll shoot
her in one of the reenactments of this
that I saw and I'm not sure how accurate
it is in one of the reenactments it
looked like the person had taken one of
them out of the car killed her somewhere
else and then brought the body back
later you know what I mean I don't know
if that's accurate but that was one of
the you know one of the reenactments I
saw showed it happening like that so
there was that whole thing so nothing
nothing ever came of like any of the
people that knew them that investigated
her anything so then there wasn't
another one for almost a year then there
was this one that was a guy his name was
David nobbling he was 20 and he was with
this girl named Robin Edwards now she
was only 14 and some people are like
raising eyebrows at that evidently from
you know some of the other podcasts some
of the research that I've done
she acted much older their age she was
this was the 80s I don't think that was
quite as much of a stigma I don't think
it was much as is now how old was he 20
you age of consent might have been
around that time around that
in Virginia so that might have been
legal then it might have been yeah so I
mean it yet is weird but it's like I I
can see what people were like Paul 2014
that's a lot but you know by all
accounts she was very mature for her age
she was sexually active and you know
things like that so the two of them go
out on a date or Lovers Lane or whatever
the hell it was they were doing and now
these two were actually found they
actually found David's car um a few days
after like they went missing
and they found his car the keys were
still in the ignition his wallet was
sitting on the seat nothing had been
taken radio was still on three days
later they found the bodies now these
two had been shot execution-style like
in the back of the head it looked like
what happened was that the person shot
the 14 year old girl
at which point like shot her and then
David was either next to her and then he
tried to run away and then because he
had two gunshots one in the back of his
head and one in his shoulder so it
seemed like the guy like shot him and he
fell and then he kind of let it caught
up with him right so yeah so there were
these two again no rape no robbery
nothing like that now this is a
significantly different mo than the
first crime so I think at first they
didn't really connect them even though
it's similar you know Lovers Lane type
thing double murderer because I'll just
kind of like an ambush he ran up on him
where they were in the car and open
fired yeah it sounded something like
that or force them to get out of the car
or something now what I'm gonna say I
was gonna save this will it end but I
but I will tell you what they were
thinking because a lot of the victims
were found or their cars were found like
their wallets were found like on the
seat most of the cars had the windows
rolled down or rolled halfway down so
they started to speculate that maybe the
killer or killers was a cop or
pretending to be a cop or a park ranger
because a lot of it was kind of like you
know that's like a Wildlife Refuge type
of
like park you know sub Park Rangers or
someone pretending to be a park ranger
so someone that would pull you over
because they're assuming oh people got
their wallet out and rolled their window
down right because they thought it was
like an authority figure like they were
being busted for something right so
that's one of the theories also because
several of the cases had that detail of
you know like the wallet being there and
the ones about right and stuff like that
probably impersonating a policeman
that's yeah that's one of the theories
that they're thrown around now a couple
months later after the after those two
were discovered David a Robin then there
was another one so this was Cassandra
Haley and Richard call now they were
both college students and this was like
their first date I think she was 18 or
19 and he was maybe 21 something like
that so they had been at this party in
Newport News this was in April of 1988
and then they left and vanished now
these two their bodies were never found
but listen to this creepy [ __ ] so they
go to I don't know if they went there on
purpose or if the killer drove the car
there or what but they found their car
like kind of parked across from like the
York River the got Richard calls dad
drove the Colonial Parkway to go to work
in the morning and he saw his son's car
it wasn't like a 1982 Toyota Celica was
red and he saw it parked on the side of
the road and he thought it was funny
because he's like the door was open and
he stopped and he looked in there he's
like the door was open the keys are on
the ignition the glove compartment was
open but there was like nothing I mean
that's weird but like he was kind of
like huh
well maybe him and his girlfriend just
went down to the beach and fell asleep
or something like that so he didn't he
thought it was weird but not weird
enough you know to kind of take it
further or get like super upset about it
so he was just kind of like huh okay
well so he just went on to work now a
couple hours after that then the park
rangers came
and you know we're like treating it like
an abandoned car like they had kind of
like you know taped it off and
everything like that now the weird thing
about this is when the park rangers got
there they said that there was like
clothes and belongings in the car like
Richards underwear his wristwatch his
and his glasses were in the car also um
Cassandra's purse and her bra and one
shoe now the weird thing about that is
that when Richards dad stopped when he
saw the car he didn't see any of that
[ __ ] in there so I don't know if like
the park rangers did I don't know like
if they took stuff and then they put it
back because they were like oh [ __ ] now
it's a missing-persons investigation and
we like touch it when we weren't
supposed to touch it or if the killer
came back or what but the dad is saying
no he didn't notice any clothes or
anything he said he thought it was weird
because the door was open and the keys
were in the ignition still but he didn't
say anything about seeing any clothes in
the car but when the park rangers came a
few hours later and were treating it
like abandoned car they said there was a
bunch of clothes in there that it was
their stuff like in the backseat or
whatever so that was pretty weird
feeling that killer went back yeah
that's a possibility you know he didn't
know that dad was there yeah you know
for some reason he had to close with him
he put it back in the car yeah it had to
be something like and maybe he was even
oh you know it's creepy it's like maybe
he was even watching the dead like maybe
he was coming back and he had the
clothes and who's gonna put him in the
car and then he saw the dad there and he
was like hiding and like watching I'm I
don't know I think he saw the dad he
would have been spooked and then said
I'll [ __ ] the clothes and then left it
all goes yeah I'm gonna do something
that's really creepy but the fact that
they they didn't find their bodies and
it's funny because well it's not funny
but like I said um the cops at first
were like oh well maybe they were just
you know they kind of took off their
clothes and then they went down to the
beach to skinny dip and like the
families were like dude it was 40
degrees outside
no one's skinny-dipping in 40 degrees in
Virginia and it's like also where they
were parked there like it was really
kind of a pain
in the ass like to get down to the water
like all these dunes and [ __ ] like that
there like nobody is skinny-dipping from
here that's like the dumbest thing ever
so the cops actually did start dredging
the York River like by there now the
weird thing is that they dredged the
river and they found a body and at first
they were like oh well here's but it
wasn't either one of them there's
another body it was this other guy it
was like some middle-aged guy who had
apparently like fallen out of a boat
like accidentally and drowned
how long before I don't know okay this
was like four days after they found the
car okay like because they were
searching the river they were driving
their fun random [ __ ] yeah and
they just found like a random body I'm
like what are the [ __ ] show here is
yeah yeah because they thought oh we
found one of them and then they're like
no that's like a middle-aged guy my son
is like 21 yeah so apparently this was a
this wasn't a murder victim I don't
think it was just a guy that died like
yeah yeah so I was like that's gotta be
like the craziest thing especially like
rural Virginia yeah it was like finding
bodies popping up well we were looking
for other ones but we found this one so
they fine no they never found that they
never found those two now the last two
that are attributed to the Colonial
Parkway serial killer and that doesn't
mean that there weren't other ones that
they think might be related but these
are the last canonical ones now this was
Anna Maria Phelps she was 18 and Daniel
Lauer who was 21 another thing that I
forgot to mention is that most of these
murders took place on a holiday weekend
and this particular crime took place on
Labor Day weekend of 1989 now Anna Maria
was actually dating Daniel's brother
whose name was Clinton I think and they
were going actually Daniel was gonna be
moving in with her and his brother like
that like her and the brother were gonna
get married and Daniel was moving out of
their parents house and he was gonna
move in with them like could you know be
like a roommate and so they were riding
together to the house to Virginia Beach
so they so they take off they disappear
later on their car is found at a rest
stop a band
and now the weird thing about where the
car was found was the rest stop was on
the westbound side of the highway when
they should have been going east
meaning that probably the killer left it
there they probably didn't leave it
there that's what they're thinking he
got in their car and drove it yeah and
and there's and there's evidence to
suggest that now all of their stuff was
still in the car except for an electric
blanket and they found that later on but
you know the wallets were still in the
car ever their purse still had money in
it everything this guy doesn't even
steal no he doesn't take anything like I
said all the purses they still had money
all the wallets they still had money in
them so and they sent another weird
thing that they found too was that
annamaria had you know like a roach clip
like a personalized ur to have like
feathers on it and stuff
peg in a day yeah and she had this oops
yes was 89 yeah and whoever had killed
her presumably left it like clipped on
the window like the window was halfway
down and he left it clipped on there hmm
like I don't know if she did that or if
the kazuma killer did that for whatever
reason so later on I think it was
actually six weeks later they found the
bodies some hunters found it in October
1989 and this was like in the woods near
Bridgman Virginia the two bodies were
you know horribly decomposed they had
been covered with the electric blanket
that they had that the killer had taken
from the car now they couldn't determine
what Daniel hours cause of death was
because he was too decomposed annamaria
they saw that her bones had like a lot
of slashes and stuff on them so they
presumed that she had been stabbed
multiple times now they the car liked
the undercarriage of it there were weeds
like stuck on the underside of the car
that matched the weeds where the bodies
were found so they're presuming that the
killer either was hitchhiking and got in
the car or you know somehow forced them
into the car and then drove them out
there killed them and then drove the car
back to the rest stop and abandoned it
right so they're thinking that that's
probably what happened now the shitty
thing about this is like this is the
late 80s um they did have DNA thank them
but it wasn't you know it wasn't as good
as it is now I guess so I feel like a
lot of the DNA stuff was kind of botched
and in particular one thing that like I
said none of the female victims or the
male victims seem to have been raped
there was no sign of sexual assault or
anything like that but some people were
upset because the in the first case
Cathleen Thomason and Dow ski she they
they took rape kits but then they
ordered them destroyed like without
doing them now hold on all these
homicides yeah in what area are we
talking about here 20 miles a hundred
miles to be from within each other
what's linking them other than just the
EM the Colonial Parkway along that
colonial era because the Colonial
Parkway is only 23 miles long okay so
it's still on that 23 Mile Road yeah
it's like it's it's either like right
off that road or like within like not a
very long distance
yeah and we're talking about how many
years about three or four years yeah
three or four years yeah so I guess
they're linked yeah and it and like I
said even though some of em OHS were
kind of different because some of them
were shot some over stabbed sounds like
some kind of thrill killer look kind of
like kind like zodiac where he thinks
he's hunting these people yeah and
you're not the first person to have said
that it's like you know I don't think it
was the same person as the zodiac
because that person probably oldest [ __ ]
right now and I don't see some geriatric
[ __ ] like run around doing this
kind of [ __ ] but it was someone like
that someone could drive mentality yeah
drive he was old enough to drive
probably had his own car I drove out
there yeah and then would use their car
to drive himself back to his car yeah
maybe he would stash his car and walk
yeah a bush scene kill them take their
car and use their car to drive back to
where his was and they make a switch
something like that yeah now you'll see
a map right hinata meaning it's
to really kind of figure it out but he's
got to be going to and from those kill
zones some yeah so he's driving but he's
also driving their car so that means
he's setting up somehow yeah Yotam oh
yeah
because he's not gonna drive away from
his car using their car right you know I
mean he's taking their car to get back
to his car to get back to his car yeah
so like you said is particularly in this
last case here you know the fact that he
just left the car abandoned again door
open whole deal left it on the written
the rest stop on the westbound part of
how he was parked in that right that
means he probably parked there yeah for
whatever reason and then he walked maybe
he walked across the highway to the
maybe they stopped at the rest stop
across the because they were going east
they were not going west right that's
why everyone was confused cuz they're
like why why is the car parked there
because they were going the opposite
direction wherever he's lying and wait
he's walked there yeah that's what I'm
thinking yeah because he had to use the
car to get out of there
out of there that's kind of what I'm
thinking too yeah
and now I here's the weird thing is that
I'm thinking like I said a lot of these
cases because they found the wallets out
and in one case you know the glove
compartment was open and stuff like that
which seems very much like you getting
pulled over by a cop so this is either a
cop or someone who's pretending to be a
cop that's I'm I'm going with that
because it seems like there's not a lot
of they're not really finding a lot of
signs of struggle like with the victims
so I feel like this is a case where
somebody thinks it's a cop you think
you're getting pulled over you're like
oh crap I'm getting pulled over he comes
up he asked for your license or whatever
and then either pulls a gun on you or
whatever I find it odd that he's not
taking the money he's not even looking
in the wallets I find that very weird to
most serial killers do yeah because look
in the wallet they want the ID yeah I
mean who turns down free money
that's what creeps me out the most it's
like it it weirds me out too that none
of the girls none of the women were
raped but that's less weird then
no one taking the money like you said
it's like why would you leave it there I
mean from that perspective if you're if
you're gonna go to all the trouble to
like kill some people and there's some
money in the wallet it's like why
wouldn't you take that he must have
money yeah that seems very strange why
would you walk away from fifty sixty
hundred dollars yeah betrayed there's no
way to trace that it just seems like
this is you must be so jacked up yeah
I'm so into what he's doing he's
forgetting about it maybe that's what I
think he's forgetting to check that he's
getting all this rush of endorphins from
this kill you know and he's making sure
he's getting a clean getaway and he's
doing all his little things before he
leaves and forgets all about the money
and then probably later on he's like oh
you know what I left this wallet I
didn't even see if there was any money
next time I'll check and then the next
time he just gets he gets it again yeah
yeah to me that just seemed very very
weird because in a lot of other aspects
of the case he seemed to have his [ __ ]
together if indeed he is posing as
someone else if indeed he is doing as
you said and he's parking his car in one
location and then walking to this other
location and then using their car so it
seems in a lot of ways that he's fairly
organized yeah so it doesn't seem like
he's running around in like a frenzy
like a berserker or a nothin come was
kind of like he's going through a
pre-planned mission he's got it
memorized but he forgot to memorize the
part about check that wall to see if
there's any money in it yeah now some
have speculated um you know particularly
because the first couple was a lesbian
couple the second couple was you know
it's a big age difference that this
might be what they would call a
missionary style serial killer a
missionary type serial killer one that
feels like they're punishing sins yeah
so yeah what else into steel yeah that
would also explain why he wasn't
stealing the money or raping the women
because he just feels like it's his
righteous duty right to kill people that
he perceives as sinners for whatever
reason in his like crazy fucked-up mind
so that's the
that makes sense in that context could
be and I'm gonna say too because there's
another crime that happened later on
that is not in the canonical crime but
it sounds very similar and that was also
a lesbian couple and they think that
might have been if it wasn't the same
person that did all the other ones it
was for sure probably the same far away
worst one how far away was it from all
these murders not very far this is all
like the very the same area this is all
the same area so the case pretty much
after that one in 1989 the case pretty
much went fallow they just they really
didn't have any leads they had no idea
what was going on now there was kind of
a weird thing where a bunch of
crime-scene photographs like really the
really gross like gruesome graphic ones
were released not exactly to the public
but they were released to like police
school or FBI school or something for
use in like classes without permission
now the person that kind of blew the
whistle on this his name was Fred at
well now this happened in about
2009-2010 now in a way it was good
because him drawing attention to hey
they're using these like horrible crime
scene photos and they're getting out
into the public when they're not really
supposed to you know and we didn't have
permission to like release them or
whatever and that actually brought
attention back to the case so they
started working on it again however Fred
at well according to many of the victims
families he's I'm not gonna say he's a
suspect in this [ __ ] but he's for sure
person of interest
because a lot of the families have said
look he acts super weird he is super
obsessed with these crimes he's always
trying to like involve himself with the
families like when they do things about
you know when they like talk to the
press about the murders or whatever he's
always like trying to involve himself
and also he was a cop at one time but
later on he kind of went off on a life
of petty crime like he got arrested and
yes you sounded in 2014 or something
like that for like holding up a woman in
like stealing a hundred dollars like
holding her back on point yeah he didn't
hurt her but he like held her at
gunpoint
so that guy like I said I'm not it's I
don't think he's like officially a
suspect or anything but some people are
like hmm that's a little weird but like
I said does he has the skills needed to
uh yeah make a false arrest on somebody
and you know talk him through it you
know you might be maybe he still has
uniforms right so that's what some
people are saying because he did used to
be a cop and it's like he would not a
carry himself yeah and it seems weird
even though it was good that he was the
one that brought the the whole
photograph thing to it to attention and
probably drew more you know got more
attention back on the case again because
it had gone cold it that might have been
because he was super obsessed with the
case because I'd seem like a yeah
because it seemed like he was always
like thinking about it so he got mad
when he was forgotten he started to call
him and say hey you forget about me yeah
it seemed very much like that it seemed
very much like that so he's kind of a
person eventually I don't think they
have like any evidence worried but he's
kind of like sketchy he's like a sketchy
individual and like I said a lot of the
victims families have said that they're
creeped out by him and that he does like
creepy [ __ ]
you know I mean that he's always trying
to like call them and like get involved
in stuff and they find it very
off-putting so you know there's that
whole thing so after that happened in
like I said 2009-2010 when the case kind
of got more media attention and things
and they decided to kind of you know
maybe start reinvestigating it some of
the victims families actually hired a
detective named Steve sping gola he used
to work for the Milwaukee Police
Department homicide detective and they
kind of hired him to look into the case
again and see if he could come up with
any new leads or anything like that now
interestingly he ended up writing this
big like a big long paper it's like
about 40 pages long and in his opinion
um this is not one killer he thinks that
maybe the middle ones were the same
killer but the first murder which was
the Thomas and dasky murder the the
lesbian couple
he thinks that was someone else so he
either thinks that all of these were
separate crimes or that there are at
least
two different killers which is not
exactly what the families were thinking
because for a long time they were
thinking that this was all just one
person doing this what are the
statistical odds though that's what I'm
saying it's I can see why you would
think that because the mo in the first
case and the other ones are kind of
different but not different enough that
it would lead me to believe it's
necessarily another killer you were
talking about a 200 mile stretch of road
I say yeah maybe we're talking about a
23 mile stretch of road yes you got a
gigantic area yeah within a few you know
years of each other that does sound like
a serial killer
yeah and like I said it's not you know
yes it's rare for serial killers to
change their MO or whatever but it's not
unheard of and especially one that was
early and then like a year later they
did it in kind of a different way and I
mean the fact that he did this big
overkill thing tried to burn the car and
everything like in the first case and
then in the second one he just
straight-up shot them you know there
could be a lot of reasons for that that
doesn't necessarily mean it's a
different person well although like I
said it could be a two-man team it could
be two guys working in tandem now the
second the second group would they were
shot was the yeah was the weapon
identified what kind of weapon and well
no because they yeah it's everything I
saw they said they didn't they there
were no casings there were no shell
casings they didn't find anything like
that stained ground of a pistol so yeah
they weren't sure they knew it was a
pistol maybe a 357 maybe they're a 38
they weren't exactly sure okay so but
they were kind of the only ones that
were shot and I mean like I said the the
third one
the bodies were have never been found so
they don't know what happened there
how they even died then some people even
speculate maybe that was an accident
they drowned or something like that even
though I don't buy that but so okay so
so that guy's saying this now one thing
that is maybe sort of leaning in that
direction is there was another crime in
May of 1996 and this was very similar to
the murder of the Thomas and dowse key
murder but like the first Colonial
Parkway murder this
again another lesbian couple their names
were Lally Winans and Julie Williams now
they were on vacation and they were
going up to the Shenandoah National
Forest with their dog and they were
doing like a two-week camping trip so
they go up there now this is actually a
hundred and eighty miles away from the
Colonial Parkway okay so but but it's
just very similar like the way it is
very similar to the first one so they go
to the National Forest they go camping
there last seen on May 24th by a camp
ranger he came and like gave them their
updated permit or whatever and dropped
them off in a parking lot about 5:30
p.m. now
nobody heard from them they were
supposed to come back I think lolly was
supposed to be in her friend's wedding
on June 1st and Julie was supposed to go
back to work like a couple days after
that but they never came home so then
they just started searching the
searching the forest for them now they
actually found their bodies on June the
1st near the skyline Lodge now these two
had been tied up their wrists were bound
their throats had been slashed just like
the first two women left to write
indicating a right-handed killer just
like the first two women so they and
they also had their like mouths covered
with duct tape
and stuff like that the wrists were tied
up with like pieces of fabric or
whatever again neither one was sexually
assaulted nothing was stolen like all
their stuff was still there later on
they found their dog wandering around in
the forest and he was fine so that
seemed other than the tying up that
seemed kind of similar and again this
was a lesbian couple so some people like
I said have speculated that this crime
and the early the earliest colonial
parkland crime were maybe the same
person and the ones in the middle were a
different person now how far away was it
again this was a hundred and eighty
miles away I don't think so but I mean
180 miles you can drive it that's you
know yeah that was
somebody else did that you think I think
so
tying him up it was just it was just
coincidence somebody else did that but
still not robbed and not raped that kind
of because it does seem like serial
killers in particular they're all about
that at least the raping when they're
gonna do the women I think it's more
unusual for them not to rape the women
you know or the it seem like there's
like no sexual motivation yeah a
circular usually has a sexual motive
that's what I mean
that's what that's what gives me pause
about these because it seems like it
seems like how rare is serial murder but
then how rare is a serial murder that
doesn't take any money that doesn't rape
any of the victims you know it just
seems really weird to me yeah that one
up in the in the mountains though maybe
that wasn't a serial murder maybe they
just got into an argument with some dude
he got pissed off beat him up tied him
up yeah but their throats
he wasn't even worried about you know
robbing robbing him yeah maybe you know
they got into a pissing match you know
there's no talent yeah there weren't any
more homicides in that area um no there
was one from 1984 that they think might
have been related but I'll kind of talk
about that one in a minute but you know
sounds like it might have been some kind
of one-off
yeah that one up there maybe now they
did have a suspect for this one his name
was Darryl Rice he kind of lived in the
area he was like a real like woman-hater
type of person and he had been like
convicted of some other things so they
actually put him on trial for this but
they couldn't place him in the forest at
the time he had been there the week
before but not the same week these women
were there and then when they did DNA
because they found some of the killer's
hair like stuck on the duct tape and it
didn't match so he was actually like get
a guy to trial for that well or they
said they were going to where they were
trying to investigate or something like
that yeah yeah so there was that whole
thing now as I said you know because of
the windows thing in the wallet thing
you know the FBI are strongly leaning
into the possibility because this area
yeah that's where like the FBI
headquarters are there's that's where
like the Virginia State Police
Headquarters are there's like a whole
big thing with like Park Rangers and
everything like like all right they're
in that area so they think it's very
very likely that the killer is someone
in law enforcement or someone pretending
to be law enforcement park ranger you
know cop whatever even someone like an
FBI agent is anything so they're just
thinking that that's probably the case
because like I said none of the victims
look like they had had that they had
fought the killer or anything like that
because they definitely local yes oh
yeah it was from that area he knew that
area well that's why he worked it yeah
that's all I was saying the other two up
in the mountains out to lesbians I don't
think it's the same guy maybe now this
guy wasn't going outside his comfort
zone yeah no I mean even yeah it's like
even guys like you know Bundy you know
he would he would he was far-ranging
yeah kill people all over the United
States
this guy's a local yeah it makes you
want to think that this guy's young too
this might be a guy in his 20s yeah and
maybe yeah really well you know rounded
or adapted you know maybe he grew up in
that area and that's where he's
comfortable that's what I'm thinking I
can't lean toward that too because this
is somebody that is familiar with the
area it seems like and he's
uncomfortable away from there yeah it
seems like he's kind of cruising this
road and he knows where people go like
to park um you know and he kind of knows
his way around you know the those one
bodies that took like six weeks to find
you know obviously that was kind of off
the beaten trail so he knew where to put
them
he's gonna be found I think he's kind of
uh you know kind of like a young
woodsman type yeah I mean he grew up as
a early young teenager running around in
the woods in this area he grew up out
there just comfortable walking around
that's why he was on foot yeah you know
and that 23 mile stretch a road you know
he was he knew that you know that's
that's where he wanted to work because
that's where he felt comfortable that's
the sort of thing that's the feeling I
get yeah and one thing they were
thinking too is that they're like if the
same person
did the crime in the Shenandoah National
Forest 180 miles away there said that
might actually kind of bolster the
theory about him being a park ranger or
something like that because sometime
like if a park ranger got trans then got
transferred into that area I think a
park ranger would be smart enough to
know that that would look very
suspicious to or somebody out yeah
that's true but you know there was
something like I saw a documentary about
this and I didn't see it mentioned on
the you know the thing that I was taking
notes on but I saw a documentary that
said apparently there had been before
the murder started there had been a
couple people that complained about some
Park Rangers in that area of the
Colonial Parkway that would come up to
your car and like look in there and be
like and they were acting really weird
and sketchy you know what I mean like
there was one guy doing that so I don't
know if this guy was just like psyching
himself up like if he was seen if he
could get away with being a park ranger
like maybe he wasn't even really one
maybe he heard that and was pretending
to be a park ranger yeah something like
that I kind of think he's a young guy
grew up in that area was very
comfortable in that area he considered
it to be his territory yeah he was kind
of a loner
yeah and just started doing that that's
what I'm thinking and some people have
been like that
maybe totally wrong but that's yeah the
feeling I get because what kind of guys
doing this why in such a small area
you know why is he taking their cars
he's taking their car to drive to get to
his car which means he was on foot yeah
which that implies to me a young guy
yeah it's not afraid of getting dirt
he's not afraid of walking around in the
bushes and [ __ ] you know I mean and he's
walking up to these lover lanes not from
the avenues of approach of the of the
roads yeah I think he's walking up to it
through the bushes you know through the
forest yeah and seeing who's there
watching it killing people and then
getting in their cars and then driving
to his car and if that is the case that
people did report like a park ranger or
somebody looking like a park ranger that
would come up to the windows look in
maybe he was like looking for particular
victims
and he may have not have been a park
ranger yeah I'm saying he might have
just been pretending well I've been
wearing some clothes that were
reminiscent right that because he was a
woodsman more conic right and again like
I said that if all of these were done by
the same person and this sort of happen
tonight so yeah with how the hell could
they make a proper idea at night and he
was the guy that probably had the
flashlight which is blinds you when the
other guys yeah that's yeah that's what
if people have said to if he just came
up to your car and shine the flashlight
you you wouldn't be able to see his face
I think is a woodsman you know what you
would call it woodsman you know well and
another detail that a lot of people have
kind of harped on is you know in the
first case the Thomas Donsky murder
where he tried to you know soak the car
and diesel now this is interesting
because one most people don't carry
diesel fuel around with them unless
they're on a boat perhaps or a trucker
maybe um but you'd think that somebody
that was familiar with diesel fuel would
know they didn't realize it that you
couldn't light it with just a match so
that seems a little weird maybe I didn't
know it was diesel fuel maybe now he
stole a gas can from some and thought
you thought that that was gasoline that
was actually diesel you yeah been there
tries to light it he did want to blow
himself up right I just assumed it was
gasoline yeah because I'm a man is it
too dangerous it's not worth it's gonna
you know it's gonna go boom
yeah you know once I put touch the the
lighter to it which Mitch means that
maybe he stole that yeah you know he
didn't know it was diesel
yeah that's kind of good cuz some people
have said oh maybe he came in on a boat
or something like that just because the
diesel fuel cuz that's something that
people on boats whatever likely he saw
can and maybe that cam was in the trunk
of the car didn't know about yeah yeah
that could be
I think the card that the first two
victims were found him I think it was a
hatchback actually like from what I saw
cuz I saw some of the pictures and
they've been in the backseat yeah it's
possible like I said it's it's diesel
fuel is not something that most people
carry around with them so it just seemed
like a weird detail like where did he
get that firmware why did he have it you
know what I mean maybe he found it on
his way there yeah and assumed it was
gasoline he stole it now another
interesting thing too that a couple
pointed out as I said that there was
actually an earlier murder in a similar
area that was sort of the same now this
actually happened in August of 1984 and
again this is another couple mike
margaret and donna hall they went to a
party they left him about quarter to
midnight and they said that they were
gonna go camping over the weekend now
when they didn't come back on sunday
their families filed missing-persons
reports now on August 21st a couple days
later this guy's walking his dog behind
these apartments and he sees a Jeep
that's like pulled into like a ditch or
something that's like backed into a
ditch the passenger side door was open
the keys were in the ignition ashtray
was open and they found like a bandana
like hanging from the rearview mirror
and there was another bandana tied
around the clutch like the you know that
thing nothing was stolen out of the car
suitcases in their clothes everything
like that the guy walks around behind
the car and finds two bodies underneath
a blanket and this is Mike and Donna now
Donna was clothed but did not have shoes
on she did not appear to have been raped
they looked like they had drunk a beer
like split a beer smoke some cigarettes
stuff like that there were no drugs or
anything like that but then later on
they found that whoever had killed them
presumably had drugged them with Demerol
and then had slit their throats so I I
don't know how that happened yeah so
they think they died between 1:00 and
2:00 in the morning on August 18th they
did find DNA at the scene that belonged
to an unidentified third person but I
match the hair that came out of the
other thing not that I know of I'm not
really sure like I said now this
happened two years before that first one
so they're not entirely sure if this one
was really this is another possible one
that's related just because it was in a
similar area it was another couple you
know they were both stabbed nothing was
stolen some of their drug
Demerol yeah which means you have to
have access to their food yeah that that
doesn't sound right it sounds like
somebody who knew him that yeah it might
have been very very well and they they
also found some blood in the car that
they think was from the killer because
it was like dripped and not splattered
and so like it looked like the killer
was like poking through the car for
something could have been they took the
Demerol themselves yeah possibly
they didn't find like any drugs like any
drug paraphernalia like at the scene or
anything like that but when they did the
autopsies later they found that they had
been drugged with Demerol and they also
both had their throat slashed so there's
that so there's that whole thing so
again this case you know I'm sure I left
a lot of details out and stuff like that
but I'm just trying to hit like all the
main points so this person or people is
maybe still running around out there
they have no idea who it is I don't even
think they have any suspects for this
other than that when the one weird guy
that Fred Atwell person that you know
talked about releasing the photos and
then was like trying to get all up in
the victims family's business and you
know later got arrested for holding up a
woman and stealing a hundred dollars um
you know like I said he's a person of
interest a little sketchy but they don't
as far as I know they don't have any
evidence like I said they do have some
DNA from some of the crime scenes but as
far as I know they haven't really like
matched anything I think there was like
another one investigators said that
maybe they were talking about this one
guy whose name was Michael nicolau and
the thing about him is that they know
for sure that he murdered his first wife
his second wife he tried to run her over
with a car I'm not sure if he succeeded
and then he committed suicide now the
weird thing about this guy was that when
the killings stopped in Virginia because
he lived in Virginia the killings
stopped there but then he had moved to
Florida at that point and that's when he
killed his wife and stuff like that and
he was also living in Vermont during the
time when the quote-unquote Connecticut
River Valley murders were going on which
I have to do a show about that too
that's like a huge case that I only just
found out about it when I was
researching my book and that's like a
whole other [ __ ] ton of women killed but
so they're kind of looking at that guy -
they're like they're not they're not
sure entirely if the timelines match up
and this guy is dead now like he
committed suicide
later on but he did seem to be in some
areas where some serial killing and some
murdering was going on and it did seem
kind of strange that you know wherever
he moved to coincidentally there seemed
to be like all these murders happening
so as I said that's the only other name
that I see come up his name Fred at
Wells name and that's pretty much it and
they really don't have a lot of anything
else to go on the whole thing about well
he was there during this time and then
when he moved over there there was other
murders at that time I don't really buy
that kind of stuff because there are
murders happening everywhere at all
times and people move around yeah so no
matter where you go in this country
there's some murders happening in that
area I know what happened you know yeah
well they're only saying that occasion
well no they're only saying that because
he for sure did kill his first wife and
attempted to murder his second wife
later on in Florida so they're thinking
well he's a murderer for sure we're just
trying to figure out like who else he
might have murdered yeah because you
guys that are you know in delayed
domestic stuff they kill girlfriends
because they can't control their
emotions yeah but then them guys they
don't they don't kill people that they
don't know or random women it is kind of
like it's like the abusive boyfriend or
the stalker boyfriend type you know they
have that it's they have to stamp those
kind of guys yeah it's usually an
emotionally needy dude don't leave me
baby I'm gonna kill you you know yeah no
I can that's a different psychological
yeah then a stranger right yeah it's not
the same thing
serial killers generally don't I mean
sometimes they'll start out with someone
they know or that they kind of know but
then they they're not looking for
emotional intimacy yeah
just kind of going there looking for
objects yeah get off and then go right
for their like own amusement or their
own pleasure
so it seems like because even like
people like we were saying on the BTK
show you know some of the some of these
serial killers that just kill strangers
they have wives girlfriends kids you
know that they I don't know if they care
about them necessarily but they at least
don't kill them and then if you look at
these look at serial killers they're
kind of unlikely to kill the wife or the
girlfriend yeah because there's a
connection there yeah because that's
like two different do 90% of the time
that's who it is
yeah the guys that killed some of my
friends have said guys that stalk their
girlfriends the same guys a beat that
beat their girl yeah they're real
controlling or super emotional needy
type guy you know no don't leave me baby
imma kill you yeah they're like that
leave me
what's it oh if you're gonna leave me
that I can't believe you left me you
know I'm gonna kill you now well yeah
and that's what and that's what freaks
me out about like and this is what makes
me mad like when people are like tell
woman's like why don't you just leave
that abusive boyfriend like because
that's when it's most likely for him to
kill you when you try to leave him Yeah
right there I can't have you there
probably I've been scared to death I'm
gonna kill you I'm gonna kill myself
they kills the woman he goes I can't
kill myself I don't I'm too awesome
I had their two [ __ ] I'm gonna kill
myself I'm just gonna run yeah they do
they run well I got another girlfriend
yeah okay it's gonna be great we'll just
renew this cycle yeah it's a cycle it is
it's terrible alright so we are going to
take a break right now at the moment
when we come back yeah I'm gonna fill up
and I get another drink he's gonna get
another I haven't even like hardly
started mine because I was talking the
old hurt I heard on that last show that
we were guests on that last show that
the ice is like a third character we
were on conspiratorial yeah with Adam
saying we love doing that Jeff and Adam
said man that ice tom that ice that Isis
they said yeah man he had me going it
was what I don't like I'm not sure when
that shows gonna go up but we'll have to
tell you about it because yeah
I had a good time on that you can
remember what I said I forgot a lot of
stuff that I said he loves this show
yeah he like remembered like all like
the last six weeks of our topic yeah
like crazy [ __ ] that I said and then
said that yeah well yeah I'm not - and I
was just kind of like well [ __ ] because
you know I yeah I do research for all
these shows but I there's only so much
information that can fit in my brain at
once so it's like when I have like when
he's asking me like about all these
times from six weeks ago I'm like wait a
minute I don't even he wanted me that he
wanted he wanted me telling why was it
that Big Jim was drinking drinking
hydrogen peroxide oh and hydrogen
peroxide yeah Big Jim believed that if
you put hydrogen peroxide you know yeah
on a spoon and just you know drank a
spoonful of it or so that the hydrogen
peroxide would go into your bloodstream
and help oxygen go into your red blood
cells yes make you more macho and then
it's carbonating your blood drink I don
he's oh this is that rare earth deep
earth iodine let me put that into water
drink it but I've heard that iodine is
really good for you I don't know
I've heard that iodine is really good
now well they put it insult true
evidently can it can kind of raise IQ
may give you a little bit well I don't
look cute II better mentally I don't
think you need that much of it though oh
no no but he did drink a little bit of
iodine you do need some but I don't
think I think you get enough from diet
I'm losing machinist and a gunsmith he
had weird [ __ ] in his [ __ ] shop
sulfuric acid hydrochloric acids all
kinds of deadly poisons like man he
could be like murdering people and
dissolving him in barrels well I didn't
have a whole bunch of hits it was all
stuff doom a metal yeah he had like that
what's that he had a lots of cyanide in
there yes we were just it has something
to do with the bluing metal yeah that's
right they didn't use that in the metal
yeah he did all kinds of cool [ __ ] he
could shoot man I was gonna say that
when he said about a hydrogen peroxide
now I never heard of anything drinking
it but a lot of people use it for a
mouthwash
yeah he'd drink it I can't I tried to
use it as a mouthwash before but it's
just it's too yucky I can't although he
was a kind of guy I cleaned out my ear
canals with it my daddy's the kind of
guy
that if you question him on some [ __ ]
like that he pulled out like an Edgar
Cayce book and the Bible and show you in
three or four days here are you where
you're supposed to drink some
hydroperoxide you know hydroxide is
actually mentioned in the Bible and
isn't is don't something that we drink
the bottles of hydrogen find something
that kind of sounds like a dinner of
light Oh bubbly yeah amen he'd find
something that would like that's the
description of hydrogen peroxide was yes
that's Jesus knew all about hydrogen
peroxide
he totally did - he was chugging that
[ __ ] I don't think it'll hurt you you
know what I mean well those big bottles
of hydrogen peroxide you get in the
store it's only one percent hydrogen
peroxide anyway it's just it's then it's
all water it's just water with one
percent hydrogen ya know in Big Jim
though it was probably you know will
bleach it although it will bleach your
hair if you put it on your hair and
that's probably not gonna be true I
could only go in there huit your insides
I could only go in there because my
granddad kind of raised him he didn't
have he didn't have a father and this
was just long before I was born and my
granddad had the model airplane shop
yeah yeah throw gliders and he just let
Jim come in sniffily know BYE MOM
he's giving model airplanes just give
him balsa wood model airplanes and our
goes yeah I used to yeah well they were
big ones though yeah I know what you're
talking yeah big was all right so we're
gonna take a break right now so Tom can
get yet another drink and get even more
incoherent no I'm cool here I know I'm
just kidding I was in the Mackinac
Island episode yeah that was another
thing that yeah well we were doing the
conspiratorial show yeah he said I'm
saying he says that was your most a DD
show and I said you know what I totally
knew that and it's like I was gonna make
us redo it because we went off on so
many tangents I'm like did we even like
talk about Mackinac Island in there
anywhere we probably did but maybe for
like 20 minutes and the rest of it was
just like stupid if I get really [ __ ]
up again we'll do another
we'll revisit my that'll be like a
reoccurring I mean we did talk about it
but it seemed like more than half the
show was talking about other [ __ ] yeah
but nobody complained no I guess I don't
even remember doing that Jeff I know you
know yeah cuz he was like yeah and all
like that it's very funny though it's
very funny
alright so we're gonna take a break so
you can go refill is drink and what we
come back we were going to talk about
yet another depressing case that
involves highway the highway of tears
we'll be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house and we'll
continue to be honored there a long time
what's up baby cookie how are you doing
today see this is where she sits when we
record the show and there's the camera
that she puts her mouth on and tries to
eat it
isn't that right Pookie you're trying to
eat the camera will mommy and daddy
you're filming yeah I know you're such a
cute baby
god you're cute baby I know you went to
the vet the other day and didn't have a
good time but you're alright now
yeah it's all right it's all good the
faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century
volume 2 includes cases spanning the
years from 1960 through 1979 featuring
such infamous crimes as the triple
homicide at Lake Bodom
the family Massacre known as the good
heart murders the serial killings of the
Zodiac Bible John Jack the stripper and
the freeway phantom the slaughter of
dozens of women and girls along a
highway of tears and the Texas killing
fields and the mysterious death of
suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format
okay we're back here we are I'm fired up
yes he's refilled his we filled it up
got some fried chicken Kukulcan [ __ ]
that self to me i fried up some chicken
breast battered it rolled it through
some seasoned flour fried it up then
rolled it in barbecue sauce that had
butter in it made you a chicken tender
sandwich yeah is my barbecue sauce yeah
I did that earlier before the show but
there's leftovers in there so I walked
by those chicken fingers that I made I'm
sitting there in them he's in there it
was very good show really up he's a
really good cook in case I had never
mentioned that before which is good
cause I ain't cooking when I wasn't
serving in some kind of army or
paramilitary unit or something like that
I was cooking which is not the same man
[ __ ] it's nasty in those kitchens hot
but I don't cook yeah I've never done it
in a restaurant or anything but it's
like it's that looks like one of the
hardest jobs it's hard
ha ha she's hot stressful takes a lot of
discipline lots of it's almost like
being an air traffic controller yeah
running a line working on the line but
you know doing it professionally in a
kitchen isn't the same as doing it at
home at home you can cook for yourself
and you can make whatever you want
whatever you want you can spend all days
you're kinda messing around with it but
I like to do pastries and dessert you
know main courses and seafood and just
everything yeah I can make I can make
salad dressings I do everything pleasure
to make he makes really good Indian food
make good Indian food you can make
pretty Chinese food thank you all that
Chinese fast food easy easy easy
yeah well you've Hungarian Parker gosh
Prakash that's like one of my favorite
things you make alright so let's turkey
dinner oh yeah turkey dinner with
address into stopping breaking
everything giblet gravy
my aunt make my own cream style corn but
I use with a Brazilian recipe yeah
there's a real cream in it good
all right so now let's talk about the
highway of tears now this is probably a
really is this kind of a well known
series of murders and as I said they
just call it the highway of tears
because it's not one killer it can't be
they know that it's got to be several
killers over several decades because as
I said some of the cases you know a
handful of the cases were solved and
some of them are like different serial
killers that were operating
independently of each other now when
they say highway of tears they're
generally referring to it's about a 450
mile stretch of highway 16 between
Prince George and Prince Columbia Canada
now in more recent years they've also
expanded the quote-unquote highway of
tears murders you know the area to
encompass like a couple of other
highways a highway 97 and highway 5 I
think but generally when people talk
about the highway peers are talking
about this one particular 450 mile
stretch of road now this road
borders many many First Nations
communities indigenous people of Canada
so and there so there's like a lot of
it's kind of a remote area there's a lot
of poverty there's not adequate public
transportation so particularly in the
60s 70s 80s what ended up happening was
that a lot of to people that were kind
of lived in these underserved community
as many of whom were indigenous women
you know they needed to get to work or
school or visit family or go to a
hospital or something like that and they
didn't have a car because they were poor
and there were no buses or anything like
that so they ended up having to
hitchhike now so hitchhiking was very
common then and still is in some parts
of the area even though I believe in
2017 they finally established like you
know a periodic bus service along that
route you know it took them this long to
do it but prior to that you know despite
all the murders despite all the warnings
there's big huge signs you know
girls don't hitchhike on the highway of
tears all these people are missing with
all the pictures and stuff you know
people still do did it because they kind
of had to they didn't have any other way
to get around now there is the thing
about it is they're not sure entirely
how many victims because it seems like
kind of a thing where well we're only
gonna count these as quote-unquote
highway of tears murders and even though
there's these other murders and missing
people we're not going to count those
because for some reason I don't know
so there's criteria so the task force
that was kind of put together to
investigate these murders they called it
a Panna which was named after like a a
goddess or something like an indigenous
language and they had three criteria
they said well the victims have to be
women or girls like female because most
of the victims were teenage girls or you
know women in their 20s they had to have
been hitchhiking or engaged in some
other like quote-unquote high-risk
activity drugs prostitution something
like that and they had to have last been
seen around highway 16 or been found in
that area in that vicinity somewhere now
those crimes meeting those three
criteria there are 18 of those however
there are lots and lots and lots of
other ones that have some similarities
but on all similar so they don't fall
under that umbrella they do think in
that particular area that there are at
least 40 murders and missin
disappearances just in that area of
British Columbia but not all of them
fall under that umbrella so there's like
still a lot of controversy about that
now
this started in late 60s I think the
first one was either 1969 or 1970
although they didn't really do much of
anything about it until like the late
90s and like the early 2000s so and
because more than half of the victims
were indigenous women you know there has
been like a big huge thing about you
know why these murders and
appearances weren't investigated more
stringently before just because you know
these were for women they were First
Nations women you know if they had been
you know white women it probably would
have been investigated more so there's
like a whole controversy there too
it is getting better now like in I think
2015 they just allotted a lot more money
like trying to figure out like I said
they have finally put in some
rudimentary public transportation just
to try to cut down on the hitchhiking in
the area I think we I mentioned this
before and some other shows
traditionally law enforcement has always
used kind of like a triage approach yeah
because there's a lot of crimes to be
solved very few investigators and not
very much money so unfortunately you
know not everyone gets the same police
protection now it's not this is
something that your average civilian in
your average voter and your average
person out there discussing politics
they take it for granted that that
police can protect you they can not
really you have to [ __ ] cover your
own ass I mean it's sad but true you
know it the only truly safe society that
exists are totalitarian police states
and you're not safe they're from the
state so you cover your own ass well
you're never safe I mean you know that's
that's kind of like where we live right
now I don't ever feel like I'm in danger
or anything like that but I mean we're
in a glass again 'harry that has good
cops and a good income we're high for a
high priority right area not everyone is
the not everybody is that lucky because
right let's go down the socio-economic
scale you gotta take care of your own
[ __ ] even in the rural areas and comin
up mister come on out cutting in
Mississippi no you you better have your
own means of protection you can call the
police but they might get there it might
be 30 minutes from now
forty minutes just so wrong yeah yeah
well you know for every ten thousand
people there might be two cops yeah you
know and that suckers 30 miles away well
and like I said this particular Aryan
this has been going on for so long that
one seemed like there was some aspect of
victim-blaming going on it's like well
if you weren't hitchhiking then maybe
this wouldn't happen to you but like I
said you know the area where they lived
there wasn't really a good way to get
around a lot of them didn't have cars
and it's like well you know I have to
get to work and it's far away or I have
to go visit my family it's far away it's
like how the hell else you gonna get
around it's like a hundred miles you
gotta like hitchhike so you know I think
out of necessity a lot of them ended up
doing that but then in a lot of ways too
then they kind of get blamed when
something bad happens to them now it
should be noted too that British
Columbia for whatever reason seems to
have the highest rate of unsolved
murders of indigenous women in all of
Canada like I said for whatever reason
and this high the highway of Tears this
particular area seems to be and I think
we talked a little bit about this on our
London Ontario serial killer capital
show where particular stretches of
highway seem to be like prime hunting
ground for serial killers because they
are remote because there's a lot of
people hitchhiking on they're more
engaged and other types of activities a
lot of prostitution or whatever there's
a lot of poverty in the area people
won't be missed you know there's a lot
of places to dump a body function yeah
there's a lot yeah there's like I said
this everything that comes with poverty
family function drugs all that kind of
stuff you know it seems like that would
be irrelevant but it's very relevant it
is yeah if you kill a girl from a from
an others say a noble family she's
immediately missed yeah you kill one of
these girls from a dysfunctional family
it might be months before they notice
she's gone literally well because
they're all like drugs or and she's been
disappear in anyway you know it's a and
yeah that was some sometimes like some
cases I write about my book it's like
you know sometimes the girl in it
sometimes it wasn't even like you know
drugs or anything like that it's just
love the girl was a runaway yeah she
would go stay at her friend's house and
not tell us where she was so we you
don't know her she's not around much
right so she would get murdered and they
wouldn't find her for like months and
months because they just figured oh
she's off staying with friends somewhere
you know it's kind of hard to think of
like people that grew up in
yeah families that actually like cared
about where you were yeah you're not
everybody has you that if you're in a
first world country in the middle class
that might you know come as a Shia but
no there's a lot of people it's in the
den the working-class in poverty where
yes and where your kids no I don't know
they come by every now and then yeah
it's like yeah they coming go they stay
with their friends I don't know where
they're at yeah yeah it does happen and
I think that was kind of the case with
some of these and like I said because so
many of the girls were hitchhiking but
like I said most easy girl who likes
just teenagers are 14 15 years old
you know hitchhiking to go see their
friends or whatever and then they just
either are never seen again or they find
them dead somewhere and you know so yes
they were investigated but it wasn't
only investigated to any degree I don't
think they were they didn't really
codify this whole highway of tears thing
until much later on you know but many
decades like after the crimes had
started now like I said these crimes are
connected in proximity but probably not
in you know perpetrator because there's
for sure like a bunch of people doing
these because as I said this is like a
prime hunting area so so these crimes
had been going on since like I'll get
into the victims in a minute
but these crimes have been going on
since about the late 1960s finally it's
about 1981 the Royal Canadian Mounted
Police they finally kind of get their
stuff do they get a conference and
they're like okay look there's all these
unsolved murders and like unsolved
disappearances like happening in this
particular stretch of road maybe we
should kind of like put a task force
together do something about that so they
kind of got all that together and got
all these cases together the interesting
thing is that if you go on the Wikipedia
page for the highway of tears murders
they have like a chart on this big huge
chart of all the victims how old they
were like what year they disappeared
where they were found or if they were
ever found and then they kind of have
like the description of what happened to
them now only a few of those like I said
are official like eep anna highway of
tears murders and some of the ones they
put in there seemed not serial killers
because some of them they knew who did
like some of them it was like their
boyfriend or their stepdad or something
like that a couple of them were like
arsons that like kill the whole family
so I'm not really sure what connects all
these particular crimes that they put on
the Wikipedia page because some of them
didn't seem to have anything to do with
like a serial killer that was picking
people up and killing them and dumping
them so if you want to go look at that
I'm not gonna go into that whole list
because it's [ __ ] gigantic and a lot
of the cases seemed like they were not
really relevant to the highway of tears
thing and I'm not really sure why
they're in there but no you know not
like it's not a terrible murder but I
don't think they had anything to do with
this particular series so like I said
1981 they got all this this [ __ ]
together and started kind of trying to
put together some you know reason why
this was happening trying to find some
suspects things like that so then in
there doing that and it takes till 2005
before they finally put together the II
Panna thing that we've been talking
about now initially there were only nine
victims on it nine women because three
of the victims that they were looking at
it first and this was Alicia Germain
Roxanne tiara and Ramona Wilson those
the murders of those three girls were so
similar that they said okay well maybe
this is a serial killer or several
serial killers so we're gonna put all
these under the same umbrella as I said
another first at first they only had
nine but then they decided that they
were going to expand the reach out a
little bit and kind of take in a little
bit more of highway 97 and highway 5
which kind of connects to highway 16 and
then they went up to 18 so as I said II
Panna highway of tears murders
officially 18 probably more like
40-something they're thinking so as I
said there was kind of like um criteria
that you had to do now in 2005 I think
one of the things like I said that
people kind of got upset about when they
started this eeep Ana thing in 2005 it
was not only in response to these three
particular cases being very similar but
also because this one girl Nicole Howe
are who had gone
saying now she was one of the only ones
that was not indigenous she was a white
woman so people are like oh well now you
care about it now no white woman
disappeared you know now you're doing
something about it so there was that
whole thing too and like I said there's
still like a lot of bad blood between
the investigators in between like the
First Nations communities because
they're like you know it's kind of too
little too late we've been telling you
to do something about this for like
decades and no one listened to us and
all these people were vanishing and
stuff like that but like I said they are
doing something about it now as I said
even though it's kind of too late now
so now let's talk a little bit about I'm
just gonna do like a little bit of these
these are like the official highway of
tears victims now your first one
Gloria moody now she was 27 years old
had two kids she was last seen leaving a
bar in Williams Lake British Columbia
and then her body was found on 26th of
October in 1969 most of these women were
the the causes of death were kind of all
different some were stabbed some were
shot some are strangled almost all were
raped as far as I can recall but like I
said no one is no one is speculating
that this is all the same person but
there's definitely some truckers or
something like that like there's several
of them operating in this area the next
one was July 1970 this was Micheline
pair she was hitchhiking in Hudson's
Hope of British Columbia along the
highway and then her body was found
August 8 1970 she was 18 years old next
one was Galway's she was 19 years old
she was also hitchhiking in October of
1973 her remains were not found in it
until April 1974 now they actually had a
suspect in her death this was Bobby Jack
Fowler now he is this American serial
killer and they actually had some
evidence linking him to a few of the
other victims it on this list they
didn't have enough evidence to convict
him in the particular case of Gayle ways
but they're pretty sure that he was the
one that did
he did at least two or three of the
other ones that they know of so there's
so there's one serial killer right there
and there's like two or three other ones
do that they're looking at that they
think did some of the other ones
now the next one was Pamela Darlington
she was also 19 she was found in a park
in November of 1973 same they also think
that Bobby Jack Fowler American serial
killer was responsible for her death as
well but don't have enough evidence to
pin it on him the next one was a Monica
Ignis she was 15 years old she was last
seen walking along Highway 16 in
Thornhill in December of 1974 four
months later her body was found a few
miles east from where she disappeared
the next one was Colleen McMillan she
was 16 years old in August 1974 she left
her house and she was going hitchhiking
along highway 16 she was going to visit
a friend of hers and a month later they
found her body now Bobby Jack Fowler did
kill Colleen McMillan they got DNA off
her body and they matched it to him in
2012
now Fowler died in prison in 2006 so
he's dead now but they they know for
sure that he killed her they have DNA
evidence and they suspect that he killed
some of the other ones as well not all
of them because you know if he wasn't
around and there were some that happened
after 2006 so so like I said this is
more than one I don't even know this guy
maybe we should do a show on him
yeah well like I said we're trying to
get around to like doing all these
serial killers why don't you go write it
so there's a lot of well in so many
serial killers it's like every time and
you know you guys that that give me
recommendations like in the comments
like some of you guys come up with
serial killers that I have never heard
of before and I'm like super into this
true crime [ __ ] like I write about stuff
but every day I'm coming up with some oh
here's another serial killer that I
haven't heard of and it's you know we
talk about how rare it is and it is but
I guess there's so many people in the
world and you know you're going back in
history to because some of them are dead
now like some of them are a long time
but it really is alarming you know that
the same handful of them get talked
about but there's so many other ones
that just never get brought up yeah
even ones that killed like the same
number even more people as some of the
ones that everybody knows because some
are just generic Stranglers I guess yeah
and there's like nothing quote-unquote
splashing about them or something I
don't know like I was I was kind of
thinking about this the other day cuz
somebody mentioned something in the
YouTube comments I was like what is it
about some serial killers that make them
more memorable than other ones you know
what I mean it's like you know yeah when
you get ones like Ed Gein it's like yeah
I wear peoples skins and say ok now
people are gonna remember that kind of
[ __ ] but what you know what makes
somebody more like what made like BTK
BTK because that case was out there for
a long time and then when they found him
you know look at Dennis the trail look
at him look at Dennis yeah no I got
sexual problems you don't mess that's
enough you're gonna remember that sexual
problem yeah I got very upset thing ever
I'm good and you know and he did the
whole you know I just want to punch him
right in the [ __ ] ball yeah the whole
courtroom confession that went on you're
not I mean of course you're not gonna
forget that then but then you look at
like lose a little Gary Ridgway that
little worm he you know I mean the only
reason why you remember him is just what
a worm he was ones that are wormy like
that to you but people don't remember
them well they remember him because the
sheer numbers yeah there's so many of
them that he killed and left him along
the end of the Green River Killer
I won't rot along the riverbank that it
built it up he built he built himself up
to be something and then when he finally
seen me just a little worm well aren't
they oh yeah I that's what I kind of
feel like I feel that's why and I think
I said this before it's like we really
don't like want to glamorize these guys
or anything like that but it's like
dudes are all [ __ ] bags yeah it's just
cuz every time you see him it's like I
don't know you build them up in your
head it's like some big monster or
something and then you see him it's just
some schlub they're nobodies you know it
looks like David Berkowitz for Christ
you know what I mean but yeah so yeah we
should do a show about Bobby Jack Fowler
because
he did kill a bunch of people including
like they think a bunch of the highway
of tears people not all of them but he
probably did some of these now the next
victim as she was shoot this one was
just a little girl she was only 12 years
old Monica Jack um this was in May 1978
she was actually not hitchhiking or
anything like that she was just riding
her bike down the street in Merritt
British Columbia now actually she
disappeared for a really long time they
didn't find her body until 1996 now they
actually caught the guy that did hers
and this is yet another serial killer
Gary Taylor handlin he was 67 when they
caught him they charged him in 2014 he
had also killed another little girl who
was 11 named Katherine Mary Herbert that
was unrelated to the investigation but
he killed her as well now he says that
he didn't kill Monica Jack I think he
did confess to killing the other girl
but the investigators say no that he
confessed to an undercover officer he
actually went to trial in 2018 in
British Columbia and it was just like a
few months ago that he was found guilty
January 2019 he was found guilty of both
of the murders the two little girls so
that's another [ __ ] multiple killer
that nobody's heard of Gary Taylor
Hanlon um okay so the next one was
Maureen MO see she was actually 33 years
old she was also hitch hiking near
Salmon Arm British Columbia on the 8th
of May in 1981 and her body was found on
a lane off of highway 97 again she was
one of the ones who was added later when
they expanded the locale a little bit
there was actually there was another one
named Shelley bass cue she was only 16
she was walking a street in Hinton
Alberta and actually she disappeared on
May 3rd 1983 body has never been found
Alberta Williams disappeared in August
1989 at the age of 24 her body was found
several weeks later near Prince Rupert
British Columbia the next one was
Delphine
Nicole disappeared on June 14 1990 16
years old also hitchhiking on highway 16
she was never found
there was another 16 year old Ramona
Wilson hitchhiking to her friend's house
and Smithers
Columbia on June 11th 1994 her remains
found April 1995 alongside highway 16
there was another one 15 year old
Roxanne Siara disappeared November 1994
body found off highway 16 near burns
Lake British Columbia Alecia
Germain 15 years old tell you what this
guy's got some for young women don't he
yeah these are all 15 16 15 yeah almost
all of them were teenagers yeah go to
its trouble in that area to have all
them teenagers walking around yeah on a
company yeah yeah yeah damn well like I
said it seemed like I was watching a
documentary about it that had been made
I think only a year or two ago and the
guy that was out there he was out there
at the highway of tears and there were
people hitchhiking like right like
behind it B's like look there's somebody
hit checking right now even though it's
like I said they have a huge huge sign
they don't hitchhike yeah yeah it's like
what else are they supposed to do they
have to get around we do and they
finally put a bus there but geez take it
for granted here in the United States
mad cars are cheap yeah car for 500
bucks
yeah I mean well those girls are too
young to be driving anyway yeah Marty
young dude yeah you can get a permanent
what here
I think they've seen 15 you can get a
permit you can get a permit and you can
get a license of 16 16 right yeah
permit you can't drive at night unless
you're going to work and you have to
have somebody else in the car with you
that's like over and for you people that
don't live in the United States yes cars
are that cheap here anyone can buy one
it's not so much buying the car it's
just like paying for insurance and
paying for maintenance and gas yes some
states don't you don't need the
insurance except maybe yes I think I
think they all kind of have the no-fault
or liability you have to have P IP and
liability and if you're making payments
on the car you have to have full
insurance you can only just have P IP
and liability which is all I have
because my car is paid off and we're
talking about a socio-economic class
that couldn't afford $300 a month
talking expenses of gas and that's what
I mean that's it's it's not so much just
the buying the car that's a it's a pain
it's like all the maintenance yeah
because where they live is kind of like
out of it you know they live on like
First Nations settlements that yeah
there's nothing there so it's like if
they have to go to work or college or
whatever it's like they have to go a
long way yeah you can even if they had a
car yeah the gas and [ __ ] would probably
killing you yeah so it's like I said you
can tell them all day long please don't
hitchhike but what else are they gonna
do they got to get around you can't just
like sit at home but now they got a bus
yeah it's it's not great I think it only
comes like once a day or something but
it's better than nothing because before
there was nothing and nobody think that
whoever's doing this is a local and it's
somebody like a truck driver
it's somebody who I kind of feel like
this is a trucker bull this is about
several truckers yeah it's guys that go
down that area a trucker and they go you
know the girl them young girls down
there there's a chai can and they're
taking advantage of that yeah of course
no raping the girls would kill yeah and
like I said this has got to be more than
one I'm thinking this is probably more
like [ __ ] five or six I'm right
around up there and it it's gotta be a
trucker lane yeah because you had that
one trucker I mean truckers do this
every now and then not all of them yeah
well I mean among serial killers
truckers truckers one of the highest
rise professions yeah ever that one that
remember the guy that they got here he
was the one that they called him all
whips and chains that was his yeah yeah
that was his handle on the CB that's
back in the nineties red flag yeah he
was taken which of the girls before he
killed him a [ __ ] man he's nasty he was
doing all the BDSM in the back trailer
cops got him yeah a girl had a girl
chained up well that's a thing it's like
most truckers are lovely but among
serial killers that is like the top
profession or like at least in the top
three because look how you're
unsupervised for long stretches of time
you're driving all over the country you
know you're going from place to place
very very easy to pick somebody up at a
rest stop or pick somebody up like that
and then just dump them have several
hundred miles down the road and no one
would ever associate you it's just like
if you're already of that inclination it
just seems like the
patient would be too much for you yeah
but I definitely feel like the highway
of tears murders I definitely feel like
this sounds like a trucker well there
are many truckers yeah I think it's a
lot of truckers or people that are just
traveling through that area somebody
that takes that route regularly maybe
just a delivery man yeah yeah something
like that something like that but yeah
so okay so where was I yeah okay 1994
Alicia Jermaine she was 15 years old
it's time for disappearance body found
near in elementary school close to
highway 16 in December of 1994 then
there was Lana Derick she was 19 she
disappeared on October 7th 1995 last
seen at a gas station near Terrace and
British Columbia she was traveling east
on Highway 16 to her home in Hazleton
she was actually a college student her
body was never found so she is still
missing
Nicole huar from Alberta she was working
in Prince George she planted trees last
last seen hitchhiking from Prince George
to Smithers on highway 16 she was 25
years old body never found ever seen
pictures of these girl yeah I've got
pictures of all do they all look about
the same no so there's no
there's my type there's no type they
they're all they're all pretty teenagers
but they all you know it could be
anybody yeah so if I'm have red hair
some of dark hair some are blond some
have short hair some have long hair they
I didn't really notice a type among them
um you know so yes so Nicole Hart
disappeared in 2002 so like I said this
has been going on like a really long
time the next one was Tamara Chipman
also 22 years old she disappeared on
September 21st 2005 last seen
hitchhiking on highway 16 she was never
found and there was a girl the next one
was Alice Eric auger she was 14 student
at DP Todd's secondary school in Prince
George British Columbia last seen by her
family on February 2nd 2006 body found
at February 10th 2006 in a ditch along
highways
tene now those are the canonical EEP
Anna does the what in general is the
method strangulation um generally yeah
most of our sexually assaulted I think a
few of them were stabbed I don't
remember if any from her shot or not um
you know but it doesn't have handguns
yeah but I think some of them were some
of them might have been but I think in
general most more strangled or stabbed
good and I think almost all of them were
sexually assaulted if not all of them
and like I said some of them they
haven't found which isn't that unusual
because like I said it's a very remote
area it's the long stretch of road and
there's like not a lot of stuff that
soil is soft there's like a lot of
animals running around up there that
would eat bodies and stuff like that so
it's not surprising that some of them
have never been found now there are also
some more cases that are like adjacent
and particularly a lot of the the
indigenous communities they're like you
know trying to bring more attention
these other cases could only look this
might not be you know on it doesn't meet
like all three of your criteria for a
panda but these are still like girls
that went missing from this area and
stuff like that
there was so these were ones that are
like kind of outside of the
investigation but still adjacent Helen
Frost 17 years old also living in Prince
George British Columbia she disappeared
on October 13th 1970 never found long
time ago yeah Virginia's ampere 14th of
October 1971 standing near a bridge on
highway 16 last time she was seen and
she was 18 years old never found
Cecilia Nicole 15 years old last seen in
1989 now they're not sure about her
because her family said that they saw
her they knew that she was along highway
16 and that's where she disappeared from
for whatever reason police thinks she
vanished from somewhere else from
Vancouver so they're not counting it in
the same you know victim pool I guess
but so there's kind of some argument
there about that
Dina bream she was 16 years old she was
hitchhiking in September of 1999
and her body was found in
December of 1999 then there was Bonnie
Marie Joseph 31 years old last seen and
Vanderhoof British Columbia in September
of 2007 I don't think she was ever found
yes she was never found
she was also hitchhiking Madison Scott
known as Maddy she was 20 years old
missing on May 28 2011 she actually went
out camping with a bunch of friends at
hogsback Lake there was like a big party
everybody kind of left her there on her
own and she just vanished they found her
pickup truck still parked there with all
her stuff still in it her cell phone we
showed up there they saw the party it
showed up there found her I guess yeah
yeah I saw the party that saw people
leave I actually saw they did a 48 hours
about the highway of tears and it was
mostly focused on on this particular
victim
Madison Scott and they talked to this
this one girl that was like kind of a
friend of hers and apparently she had
been at the same party like at the
campground and she was the last one to
see Madison and she gets like death
threats and hate mail because they're
like why did you leave her there by
herself
like cuz her and her boyfriend like left
because I think what happened was this
girl's boyfriend got like injured like
he fell or something like that and they
so she was gonna take him somewhere and
then she says to Maddie well why don't
you come with us man he's like no no
I'll be okay and then she got left at
the campground by herself but then she
disappeared me did her car start maybe
she couldn't start a car oh I don't know
they didn't say anything about that I
mean they did find her car they found
her cellphone was this car on would she
be waiting around there yeah I don't
know I think they laughed and then
somebody else pulled up yeah might a
bench prevented her from leaving yeah
might have been maybe something she knew
yeah
so I don't know fishy yeah there's like
there's like a big science fish right um
let's see the next one was immaculate
basil also known as Maki that's not a
great name yeah a great name and this
girl is also missing she was last seen
walking
Forest Service Road Northwest Northwest
of Fort st. James British Columbia on
June 13 2013 she has never been found
she was 26 years old
Anita Thorne she was actually 49 years
old she was last seen November 19th 2014
they found her car the next day at a
highway 16 rest stop but she has never
been found she disappeared now this one
is actually kind of creepy and I don't
know if this is related or not this was
a whole entire family that went missing
hmm
so this is Doreen jack and her husband
Ronald now he got a call from this dude
that he kind of knew that was like
offering him a job right so they met at
this pub and they were talking about the
job and then it was like in a logging
camp or something so he's gonna go get
the job so he packs up the families him
and his wife and their two kids they had
a nine year old and a four year old two
little boys and they pack him up in the
car and they're gonna go out to this
logging camp where the dudes gonna get
the job and the last they heard from
them was the husband Ronald Jack called
his mom from a resort at about 1:30 in
the morning
in 1989 and that was the last time
anybody heard from any of them no the
guy they are all gone the guy who was
the guy who placed the ad for the job he
check out his being legit
I suppose so because no one ever said
anything about him being a suspect or
anything like that but this whole family
like disappeared wait yeah
husband wife two low boys so they're all
gone now because those two guys wood was
a Charles Ning and Leonard Lake yeah
a place they'd place ads under they
would answer ads yeah and kill whole
families remember that yep usually about
video equipment that's right I'd
forgotten all about that see we did a
show about them and I didn't even
remember that that they did that kind of
[ __ ] right yeah though I'm like I'm
terrified to like answer ads were no I'm
not going any with house no nothing like
that
now as I said a few of these have been
solved you know Colleen McMillan the
sixteen year old they know for sure that
Bobby Jack Fowler killed her because the
DNA matched they also suspect that he
killed Gayle ways and Pamela Darlington
they were both 19 years old but they
never had enough evidence but man this
pretty sheriff goes after me young man's
constant 14 15 16 teenagers
yeah like I said almost all of these
women were teenagers and all these girls
were teenagers as I said Gary Taylor
handlin was also convicted of the murder
of Monica Jack who was one of the
highway of tears victims as well as
another little girl who was 11 years old
now there have been no new cases added
even though people are still like women
are still going missing and getting
murdered every now and then in this area
but no new cases have been added to the
official Ipana investigations since 2007
now as I said you know other than Gary
Taylor Handler and Hamlin and Bobby Jack
Fowler there are also three other serial
killers that have been charged in
various cases that are like adjacent to
this area and these are Brian Peter ARP
Edward Dennis Isaac and Cody lagea cough
now this guy this third guy he was like
he's like I think he was like Canada's
youngest serial killer he looks totally
like just a high school kid like this
little blond dumpy high school kid who
would be like on the football team or
something like that he looked at just
like that and he's a [ __ ] serial
killer damn I looked him up on the thing
because it's weird because I looked at
Brian Peter ARP and Edward Dennis Isaac
neither one of whom have Wikipedia pages
for whatever reason but Cody lagea cough
they he'd they talked about him a little
bit more and they talked about him on
that 48 hours show too because he was
kind of like suspected in some of these
murders too like the more recent ones
because he's like super young so they
know that he didn't do like any of the
older ones obviously because he's not
old enough right because like I said he
was like a [ __ ] college Stander's he
was like a 19 or some [ __ ] but he's just
like I know that serial killers don't
look like they don't have horns or
anything like that but he really really
did not look like a serial killer I was
like really surprised like to see that
guy but so yeah those
the whole thing so as I said you know
even the ones that they suspected but
and some of them are dead so they can't
really do anything about it some of
these cases are so old or they weren't
really investigated very well at the
time so they don't really have enough
evidence or anything like that so
there's that whole thing so that's
pretty much where they're stand where
they stand at it right now like I said I
watched I can't remember the name what
is the name of this one true crime show
that has [ __ ] dark minds or dark
something like I don't know and it has
like the this guy he's like a crime
writer or a crime journalist or
something like that and he hosts it and
I can't decide whether he's like the
most annoying douche in the universe or
if he's kind of Awesome you know what I
mean so you'll know what I'm talking
about
he's very um overdramatic you know what
I mean which in a way like it's kind of
annoying but it's also kind of amusing I
guess I don't know television has kind
of gotten bad over the years I'm not
really sure what channel this is on or
how old it is I just see them on YouTube
but I mean based on what you said I'm
agreeing with you it's a couple of
different guys over over the years doing
this yeah this is several serial killers
going through the area going oh look at
this prime yeah or get rich environment
right and they're hearing about it in
the media yeah part of their normal
route I think some of them they live in
that area or they're truckers or
delivery guys and they're going like you
know hey man from what we've been here
and this is where you go to do this what
wouldn't it be horrible if there's like
a serial killer like Network where's
like they're calling each other up and
they'd be like hey man go ahead is one
road and like that's not that I mean
that's not that great that doesn't
happen that doesn't have to happen
though they sure just go on the news and
be like me hear about all these girls
being dumped along this road and they're
going and the guys who haven't done it
yet are like oh they're dumping them
along those roads because it's a
target-rich environment all those poor
Indian girls down
there yeah so they start running that
route and they're like oh yeah to
certain hours it's good yes girls moving
around they're like yeah yeah this is
the place to do this yeah because they
have a high population of very
low-income girls that are hitchhiking
yeah yeah and I think it's shitty too
because it seems like a lot of the
victims like when I first started
reading about this and it depends on
what site you you know readership
depends on like what documentaries you
watch about it too because it seemed
like some of the stuff that I was
watching were like kind of categorized
the victims like a lot of over they were
prostitutes for but a lot of them
weren't a lot of them were just
teenagers that were like going to their
friend's house or like going to the
ground with a bungee thing Bundy would
say uh that's bottom-feeding yeah yeah
he'd go for the rich college girls well
yeah that's Bob like that made him some
help yeah yeah that's bottom-feeding
Jesus Christ but yeah so definitely this
this is more like this is more kind of
related to what we were talking about
when we did the London Ontario show
where it seems like it's just there's
something about this particular location
like I said it's a target-rich
environment you know there's all these
teenage girls that you know they're low
income that are low income and people
have a perception of you know them being
more disposable or no one will miss them
or whatever and they're just standing
there like thumbing a ride so it's like
it's like yeah yeah the guy the guy is
doing it isn't worried about this
concept that well no one will miss them
yeah he knows they'll miss him yeah it
doesn't matter they're low income they
have to hitchhike that's the weakness
they're going for yeah yeah they'll get
into the car with you yeah so I feel
like this is more like a location-based
yeah situation rather than like a serial
killer basis where is the first one you
know when we talked about Colonial
Parkway killer I'm leaning toward that
being one guy or a pair of guys that are
working together I think most of those
crimes were done by one guy that was his
stomping ground he knew that area yeah
well I definitely get even though the
emmos were different they weren't
different enough to make me think that
it was a different person because it's
not a gigantic it was a guy who is kind
of like an in cell loner not real
popular spent a lot of time
woods and thought he was Jason or
something you know I mean he's got like
that yeah that's actually kind of
interesting because that you say that
because jason voorhees yeah
he's not a rapist no he doesn't steal
anything he just goes and kills people
with his machete just because they're
having sex yeah the counselors and that
might be exactly what this is yeah like
I said it almost seems more like well it
you know in the Friday the 13th movies
and it's just like a weird tangent to go
off on yeah but he wasn't doing it for
sin purposes necessarily but he was
doing it to punish them yeah because you
guys were having sex when I was drowning
in the savage Shh yeah doing that [ __ ]
yeah so this the guy that did the
Colonial Parkway killings he might have
the same type of mindset like he's
punishing them because it does seem like
he's picking either lesbian couples or
couples in cars that are making out and
maybe he thinks oh boy you guys aren't
married why are you banging in a car you
shouldn't be doing that I would read
into it too much I know I'm just saying
well I'm not the first person that said
that they said that this could be like a
missionary type I kill it like he thinks
he's punishing people I think he's just
so because he's not stealing anything
he's not raping think backwards in celle
doesn't know very many people even at
living at his mom's house killing people
you don't [ __ ] on heavy metal listening
people no but i'm people don't listen to
heavy metal and goth are actually way
nicer I was actually though a heavy
metal guy I'm just talking about it now
remember that remember that what was it
super 8 mm - Danzig knees go out and
he's doing snuff flicks I don't think
you think I saw that my way yeah long
long time ago okay like I've heard of
him he be called that but I didn't know
that because I haven't seen it but yeah
so I so I think these are two different
like completely different situations
highway of tears is definitely just this
is a stretch of road that is remote that
has like a lot of people hitchhiking on
it and you know if you are so inclined
to see
real kill kill yeah inclined to circle
yeah well and but um but this is a place
where you would go where you would
probably you know get away with it yeah
you know what I mean and I think this is
at least I'm gonna say it's at least
five dudes at least over three years
yeah over the years yeah like I don't
think they're all operating at once and
I think the media kept advertising it by
talking about it yeah talking about the
girls that we're missing and the bodies
that were found so the guys well the
shitty thing is that you have to talk
yeah because like you want those people
found but the guys Invicta the guys that
were in on it and we're like why are
they all dying along this road and then
they go drive that oh this is why yeah I
don't understand these people's minds at
at all but yeah it's it because this has
been going on like I said since at least
1969 and it's still going on now there's
still people like disappearing nowadays
and still turning up dead nowadays so at
least they put a [ __ ] bus there like
I said I think it's only once a day or
once every other day or something like
that but it's [ __ ] better yeah
nothing please stop - please don't
hitchhike I know I know that sometimes
you have to go please don't you guys
that's like so so dangerous all right so
let us wrap up this show about murder on
the road or murder on the highway or
whatever the hell I called it I bet I've
called it something like that one
highway to hell well you can just see
since the 21st century you can just go
in the other room and turn on a pube and
you can listen to whatever you want to
wrap it up I'm gonna wrap it right
making my [ __ ] go all focus out of focus
why you doing it quick he's growing
Ronnie's making it go are you almost
down that oh my goodness yeah you're so
wasted all right so we're gonna wrap up
the show episode 136 okay now you're
just doing special effects all right
thank you very much for doing that it's
it makes you look better it's awful
that's like they do in like old porno
films and like is go ahead and wrap it
over to our F daughters my stuff like
that talking too much me talking too
much
okay this coming from that's very rich
coming from you you look like you do
like GI Joe oh yeah yeah yeah
action fist alright so remember if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our stop you want to do this you can
do this you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
t-shirts and mugs and all kind of fun
cool [ __ ] on there
also check out giallo games on the game
crafter calm I sell in game selling
everything I have three different games
on there I make so much stuff I just
thought how do I have time to do mixed
up and that sound stuff we can you sell
some stuff I'm just making it my job is
done look at you're making it all blurry
again stop it
alright and that'll do it for some
Belgian 400 dollars true what that makes
sense now it's it went so blurry that it
just stayed blurry for like a really
long time so hard I can make the camera
blur yeah that's what happened well
least the Kitty's not in here eating it
today I think she's outside on the porch
playing so she she didn't get she didn't
get a little cameo today on the show
we're gonna have to wrap it oh we're
gonna have to make a whole show with her
okay okay
wrap it all right so we're wrapping up
episode because listen to this we're
wrapping up 136 yeah okay okay
are you done I'm done okay are you sure
I'm done here hold it in he's not done
I'm not gonna have to leave really good
alright
that'll do it for episode 136 we will
see you next time bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]